my talk of the table is a preview of our
interview with ryan fisher who's ryan
fisher he is lady gaga's dog walker
as you may recall we all remember this
story was shot back in february while
walking the singer's three french
bulldogs in los angeles now two of the
dogs were kidnapped but were later
returned to gaga after a reward was
offered we sat down with ryan fisher
yesterday who described how badly he was
wounded
it was a severe one shot and when i went
back because i had to go back to the
hospital a second time to have the
surgery because my lung had collapsed
the people in the er who i'd seen that
night
told me that they didn't think i was
going to survive that night so and i had
felt that because i i was very awake
during while they were operating on me
that night but just to hear them say it
it was
it makes it more real
we'll have more of our interview with
ryan fisher tomorrow right here on cbs
cbs mornings he's been through a lot
guys he had a top part of his lung
removed and have the bottom part of his
lung removed he's been through a lot of
uh trauma and a lot of drama he really
is on a healing journey yeah we've been
trying to talk to him for a very long
time and he hasn't been ready to talk
really until now and this answers a lot
of questions this kind of theft is a big
problem exactly
he wasn't aware of at the time